is a happy man he got his permit to work
in Israel months ago he says this will
help him and his family earn a good
income
Adam before I got my work permit in
Israel I owed everyone money I worked a
day and was jobless for 10 in return in
Gaza I made a maximum of 15 a day while
in Israel I made a minimum of 150 a day
can you imagine the difference
many people in Gaza like Muhammad have
been granted permits to work in Israel
when this process began early last year
it was the first time people from Gaza
were allowed to work in Israel since
Hamas took power here in 2007.
foreign
often suspends or rejects the permits
based on what it calls security
situation on the ground critics say it's
a pressure tactic
according to Palestinian officials
Israeli work permits have not been
beneficial for gaza's wider economy
which has been severely affected by
constraints of the blockade the Gaza
workers Federation says that while
thousands are still waiting for their
turn eighteen thousand workers have had
their applications rejected
Israel recently announced it's also
looking into granting work permits to
hundreds of women in Gaza something
officials here in Gaza say is a
sensitive topic that needs to be studied
at all political and security levels
there are many fears within the
Palestinian Community about sending
women to work in Israel so there must be
security reservations in order to
protect and preserve Palestinian women
but many women in Gaza see this
announcement as an opportunity for them
to provide for their families
I'm certainly with this decision because
here in Gaza girls do not have job
opportunities and if any the salary is
too low imagine being paid 180 a month
for 12 hours a day
Palestinians are choosing to work in
lands from where their families were
expelled decades ago it's a hard
decision to make but they say gaza's
poverty and unemployment have left them
with little Choice Humanity Al Jazeera
Gaza